in this farming town in the north of
South Africa land since colonial times
was primarily owned by white farmers
that times have changed they claimed
that King farms in the area of which
houses won and they said that the stayed
on the phone for quite a while and the
claim was recognized by government for
all these land reform has been high on
the agenda since Nelson Mandela became
the first black president 21 years ago
but 90% of the redistributed land is not
productive this is absolute a big
warning this is what is being happening
and farms that has been claimed not
really helping the guys when the land
was given over to them the farming
enterprise came to a standstill
these people can could not keep the
momentum what was being capable for the
white farmers the commercial for
government nevertheless is pushing on
with new proposals to force white
farmers to share the land while the new
generation of black farmers is
impatiently waiting to take over how
others have been farm as many as also
the issue of not saving this key is I
don't know where does it arise from
because the people who are working on
the farms of commercial farmers our
black brothers and sisters and sisters
and they've been doing that for many
years ago ok guys as you know that after
harvesting it's important that we
cultivate the soil now you guys are
aware of that
this is open-air college at the Butley
farming school where young farmers who
managed to get a piece of land get their
training apart from teaching farming
skills trainers emphasize the need to
cooperate with white farmers we have
seen a lot of white farmers who are
willing to play a role of mentorship to
the black farmers to say ok I'm going to
guide this
type of a black farmer for him to
achieve what I have achieved in the past
the scenario of violent takeovers like
in neighboring Zimbabwe has woken up
white farmers in South Africa to
cooperate rather than fight land reform
it's time that we really talk to
government and I'd only talk to them I
mean it's about the people on the ground
we need to help the people and worth
them create the solution and go with
that to government so what happened in
Zimbabwe will not happen it shouldn't
and I don't think it was on the disputed
land of South Africa cooperation between
white and black farmers is now key